Frank lost a hundred thousand Euros in a
night his shop was one of dozens in
Marseille broken into by rioters who
stripped the shelves the store was full
of merchandise he tells me now it's
completely empty
gangs Rampage through France's Second
City through the night their aim
seemingly theft and destruction their
target whatever they could get their
hands on
Frank's store was hit twice after
clearing the shop floor they returned on
Saturday morning and robbed the
stockroom
process which began over the death of a
teenager have morphed into something
else the death of Niall is very sad but
it's just pretext Frank says a pretext
for robbing a shot
from designer stores to Independent
shops everyone was a Target
hunting rifles from this store among the
loot
the theft from this weapons store adds
another complication for the authorities
here because now they've got a group of
protesters with a stash of arms running
around the city
Jenny blames the government for the
unrest she believes a lack of
opportunities poverty and the
ghettoization of Marseilles migrant
population have stoked the anger his
government we've done everything
to arrive at this
because they Park all these young people
and parents in City
and after they are really you know they
are not happy so they want to come here
and break everything when do you think
this is going to stop
they are going to continue because they
don't they don't don't own the shops so
I think
they are sleeping yeah and after they
come and they finish the work
[Applause]
with a rerun expected extra police and
armored trucks have been sent in as
reinforcement public transports stopping
early car Parks will be closed but these
political sticking plasters May halt the
violence they won't heal France's deeper
social wounds Siobhan Robbins Sky News
Marseille